it's what the [ __ ] is going on it's a
beautiful day to be alive you're alive
thank God to give you another [ __ ]
day to walk around this [ __ ]
what you're gonna do with it that's your
decision [ __ ] you kid it's a beautiful
day to be alive gonna be 60 degrees here
70 good [ __ ] cold yesterday afternoon
I went to the park of my daughter
[ __ ] tremendous day at the park
yesterday we have another part almost
killed three little [ __ ] kids I told
you that's the feel I want to do but
it's my real inside see them same way if
you watch the movie the family with
Robert De Niro it's just [ __ ]
horrible movie but this scenes in it
like he's talking to somebody then he
loses and he so I'm stabbing a guy with
you really not stabbing okay so I was
telling you yesterday it's um my
daughter was walking on this lake plank
of death you know with that rattles and
[ __ ] yeah and some [ __ ] little
Chinese kid came up behind and we jumped
and she fell down and the kids stopped
you know say I'm sorry and that's what
goes in my heart how can it not one here
I mean you're like that with people you
like but it's your daughter how like I
don't understand how there's not more of
that stuff happening oh and then the
little kid jumps seeing her come and
she's a baby
he saw her coming he jumped in her way
and I seen myself I had a sand bucket in
my hand going up and just hit them 15
times the same bucket kids are terrible
and then what and then we wonder why
there's so many [ __ ] adults is
because it's these kids when they were
little like people don't really change
it's uh it's you know it's just a body
growing up man you know my daughter
reacted really well like she was in Park
and somebody came and took a bucket and
she looked him straight in the face is
my [ __ ] bucket and in my heart I'm
happy my wife said you have to learn to
share [ __ ] that sharing is overrated
keep that blanket [ __ ] that's your
[ __ ] bucket he wants to bump attempt
to show you dick something he's got to
do something just can't give him the
[ __ ] bucket young-sam when she's like
five or six you two are gonna take this
town over like when she can talk and you
can tell it or do things you see bug my
dream is to build a [ __ ] ninja
chick I just like the girlfriend kick
ass or whatever [ __ ] that that chick
could kick ass cos suck my dick I'm
talking about a monster of a woman I'm
talking about a woman with a heart of
gold
that ain't get the stamp in the [ __ ]
neck and I stick up for what she wants
that's what you want from a woman I want
from a [ __ ] woman I don't want a
[ __ ] woman that's a rag doll you know
it's not for me I've never wanted a
woman that's [ __ ] submissive that
she's blinking and [ __ ] bringing you
water him like that
I like a woman that holds her own
because my mother held her up yes you
know can I get you something [ __ ] you I
just love the image of the one blinking
and pretty Warner I got but it makes me
feel bad as a man when I see a woman we
started to podcast late this morning
okay we came over last night with Tom he
says you need water so there's morning I
knew in the back of my mind I had to
stop at 7-eleven I got the several
eleven to twenty five to six
okay I would have been here the corner
of [ __ ] 6:00 and I almost called you
to come up with the camera because there
was drama hey this is what we do the
office it's a dark industrial street you
know but this is 7-eleven on the corner
and I owe it 7-elevens to me
late night now a [ __ ] scary oh yeah
7-eleven now at night I I [ __ ] going
in if I got my gun in the car I [ __ ]
bullet I'm scared of 7-elevens at night
yeah so this morning and just happened I
pull up and settle and first of all
there's a guy talking to his girlfriend
and there's a cab they just got out of a
cab and he won't let me pull in cuz he's
talking to his girlfriend so finally I
beep and the girl moves but this
[ __ ] this Donnie Wahlberg
looking [ __ ] Markey he looked
like Nate Diaz the younger one okay he
stays that stance there so I don't give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know me I'll Park I
pulled the car he looks at me bro you
didn't move say something say something
and he yells off the top of his lungs
where the [ __ ] are you go and I'm
[ __ ] talking to you dumb [ __ ]
and I just keep walking hmm and I see
her and she's half asian half Spanish
you know she's a pretty girl she's been
going through some [ __ ] so I could tell
that's with him you know
and then a black guy pops up and says
man I got a little bit of money but I
don't know if we could we'll have to
walk over there we ain't got enough for
a cab and he just has the photocopy they
were looking for drugs they were gonna
get drugs with this broad you know and
he was down on the drugs so he wanted
more so he's in a furious [ __ ] mood
so who's the cab driver there's a gap
drivers just some [ __ ] out of that
whatever he's in the cab he's minding
his own [ __ ] business he's not even
involved in this so she comes in she's
sitting in the back of 7-eleven now I'm
looking for water now in the middle of
all this there's a kid going do it is
the church and I'm like dog relax you
check on my dog run laughs take a look
at what's about to go down this
[ __ ] he follows me into the
hallways boy and I'm like dog pay
attention don't worry about [ __ ] Joey
D is stupid look at what they go down
but see that's the thing a lot of people
wouldn't I'm not if I saw that I'd
probably be a little bit nervous but for
people who haven't been in that
situation they probably think it's some
people arguing well still shut your
mouth don't worry about Joey Diaz or
Jesus shut your mouth and watch the
situation play that what if this chick
says some of this idiot pulls a gun and
you're talking like it is to do to get
it together hey this is what I tell
people pay the [ __ ] attention yeah pay
[ __ ] attention don't worry about the
mountains or the beauty or the sky or
the trees or what celebrity or what
non-celebrity walked in pay [ __ ]
attention to life so this is all going
down she's at the back of the store the
black guys telling mark you Wahlberg
they can't get drugs they don't have
enough money for the cab so now they
have to walk home they have to walk to
the drug dealers house Jesus so you
could tell she don't want to go she's
had enough he's been torching her or
something they walk out and he turns
onto his hey let's go and she walks out
half making me and the cab driver now
pulls up those hey where's my money and
they they're like [ __ ] it we don't have
enough money and they give my three dots
because I'll call the police and the
chick is look like a cab driver for
support I get me
this mess mm-hmm and the cab driver goes
miss are you getting in the car like to
do her a favor this dumb [ __ ] is like I
don't have enough money and the guy runs
over and grabs her and that's when
people started calling the [ __ ] cops
they don't have a car so they're dead no
I didn't a guy from selling honestly let
it go I'm right there that's again
that's when bullets could start flying
this guy's on meth or he's coming down
on meth this is when he rose [ __ ]
don't know this okay people don't know
is just leave that guy long and down my
won-won and wait till he walks away
don't confront him if he's not killing
him which he wasn't killing her let the
cops do their job they'll get him a
block away
we call 9-1-1 ain't nothing going on
it's five in the [ __ ] of mine mm-hmm so
I had a watch always go down yeah of
course
and I mean broke potato balls they ran a
block yeah and by the time I pulled to
this corner yeah Cahuenga the cops were
already common that's how fast the
consulate cops are in this area there's
a police station down the corner so for
them to loosely I had them on the corner
they were you know they're probably hot
man and you know what you know why I
knew that looked on him same look at
when i kidnapped Gamboa
oh you're just gonna get in trouble
really it's a look that you're not gonna
stop the you end up in County Jail this
is that type of look because you got the
chick you go go for drugs this tumor
yeah valuables going on something's
gonna go wrong now what's going on in
their head cuz they know how much money
they have they know where the drug
places like why even call the cab they
took a cab to 7-eleven to take money out
of the ATM machine at 7-eleven like they
were looking oh you're in a cab you go
there Cammi like we need cash we're
gonna stop us some 11:00 we went out
from around here was it 7-eleven you
know I'm saying it's that type of drug
mind that's a drug mind that's working
you know if you've been in that
situation you get in a car with somebody
you know you don't know where it's gonna
end up so these guys got a cab tell you
the 7-eleven paid them realize they have
enough money for the speed in the blow
or the heroin and the cab so they gave
the guy a few [ __ ] dollars he called
the [ __ ] cops and that's what
that's what house carry must have been
being a cabdriver but if I have all
these things now lyft and uber they're
all these things where you're picking up
renting normal people and they're
supposed to be a background check but
one of those people who then gets shot
man like you know background checks are
expensive everybody says they do
background check but really do that but
do they really you know I hope so I'm
the same [ __ ] way how do you get in
the [ __ ] car within these strange
towns but if they're working for a
legitimate limo company they got to be
okay
I mean knock on wood I've never really
had a problem with a little more drive
or a car drive or a cab driver you know
well that's the other side of it not
only who's getting in the cab but maybe
who's your driver that's the other side
of it too you don't know what this guy's
on his mind you know if he's drinking
you don't know what the [ __ ] you doing
if you really get into it I'll give you
a really a nervous person you might not
leave the house like there's a thing
this stuff to worry about at all times
it's just like you put it in the back of
your mind bad things happen to good
people bad things could happen any time
you know you have to cut the percentages
you know those people didn't know what
they were into they're just do it you
know when you're on [ __ ] time let me
tell you something when you're on drugs
like that and you're doing a little
late-night drugs that keep you up and
turn you into a cat your eyes [ __ ]
shine and [ __ ] that does [ __ ] you know
my mental state cannot be good from the
shots that drugs those drugs put on me
you know how old do you think they've
been off from multiple days no no
probably up they probably just started
tonight you know okay I mean that
clothes didn't look dirty they didn't
look really creepy they look like they
had started mm-hmm it started coming
down but they wanted to keep it going
but people know what I'm talking about
you know I'm talking about you go out on
a Tuesday night you have a few drinks
some [ __ ] jerk-off pops up he's got
some powder or some matte that some you
do a couple bumps now it's 3:00 in the
morning and you wanna [ __ ] mourn it's
Tuesday night oh that's Tuesday night
people say
tonight somebody I'll go looking you
know you gotta wake people up [ __ ]
it's uh you know my last two years were
you know I have to write this book I
broke categories of my dark years like
what I consider dark you know what I
considered dark which is living an
addiction just surviving to control the
addiction that's all you're basically
doing everything else's [ __ ] that you
lead it's the appetizer you know even
though I was doing Adam Sandler movie
and even though I'm doing spots and I'm
traveling and all this [ __ ] nothing
compared to my little time with my
little powder okay that was the best
time of my life nothing compared to that
nobody's [ __ ] nobody let me [ __ ] him
in the ass no movie with Charles Bronson
nothing could bring the happiness F to
that little thing that I had at night my
little getaway my little mountain
getaway and I remember that I would get
high and not even look at myself in the
mirror the last two or three years of me
getting high I couldn't even look myself
in the mirror I was so disgusted with
myself but the machine keeps going and
you have to feed the whole man it's just
a higher the higher the lower the low
like why why are you so disgusted with
yourself
it was just somewhere I didn't want to
be that's why when I look at dark times
I look from 79 to 81 from 86 to 88
before I kidnapped fell it was very dark
for me like yes I was living and I was
making a good living but I was basically
living to feed the [ __ ] hole unless
you've been addicted you don't
understand what it's like just to feed
that hole everything else bleeds to feed
in the hole you know you got a promotion
at work that's great now you can feed
the whole place on Tuesday nights you
know it's just amazing how everything
went to that but after a long as yard I
told all these doors were open for me
when they did not open it took me
someplace man vicodins pills
antidepressants you know I would [ __ ]
leave the house but the only thing in
mine was to come back
at night in the daytime I kept the
animal in the cage I was great the
daytime the daytime I wrote my jokes but
the daytime nothing moved on until I got
my package settled if I had 50 bucks in
my pocket I put that 50 away I knew
there was a package tonight so that
rested me for the day okay it was when I
didn't have that $60 or $50 that didn't
rest til I was gonna get it or you know
whatever somewhere in there
now do you think and it's kind of stupid
to do these sort of what-ifs
but if not knowing how hard of a worker
you are now let's say you did a Longest
Yard type movie would something come
from it since you didn't have the coke
to worry about you know nobody could
control that you know nobody could
control that bro it's what people see in
the movies you know I want Peter Segal
to call and if a grudge match on the 8th
the movie gets released April I'm having
a problem I'm gonna call it so I'm gonna
get the different actor from the movie
but I wanted to break down with Peter
Segal for the people at home is that
there's no formula for a great movement
there's no formula for a great movie
grudge match had all the tools of being
a great movie a phenomenal movie it was
a good entertaining movie but as far as
the box office was concerned it was a
failure of sorts even though it made 30
million dollars and overseas had made 30
million dollars I wanted Peter to break
down what you can't you don't know you
don't know what a movie's gonna do unto
you [ __ ] movie you could put millions
of dollars into advertising and the
movie had millions of dollars and it was
on every game you ever see and it just
didn't do what it did people know it was
there the combination was there than
they were Owens too long or at least we
thought the combination was that Kevin
Hart Kevin Hart pops a movie two weeks
later that's the biggest movie in
January of all [ __ ] time with Ice Cube
and you know Bryan Callen and John
Leguizamo was the good movies a great
movies right along but the point being
that you never know what
thing's gonna do but the beauty of this
is you have to try mm-hmm you have to
get down and [ __ ] try it unless
you're not gonna [ __ ] and do nothing
nobody knows nobody knew I was in the
[ __ ] door I'm still not a good
stand-up comic I know for 20 [ __ ]
years yeah you're good
I don't think I'm as good as like Bill
burr I don't hear like I'm not I'm not
monologist like that you know I have
thoughts I'm talking about you know you
you never know but nothing's gonna
happen to you try not know then write it
off well it's kind of a cool and I don't
really have the experience with it cuz
I'm not a comic but from what I hear
people comics talk about the issue they
have with actors in and more so now with
movies so they wrote grudge match let's
say two years ago a year ago then they
had to cast it then they had to do the
pre-production then they shot it then
they edited it and they decided it's
gonna come out Christmas Day 2013 they
don't up until the end they don't really
know what's gonna come out with it and
they don't know what people gonna think
so they don't know how it's gonna act
but you who say I'm not a monologist
tonight you could go on stage and try
telling a story like Bill burr or like
that so in that it or it must be
exciting because you don't have to put a
year or two or three years of planning
into it and put commercials on you could
go to any comedy club right now just try
it out all right I could tell the story
about this morning with the chicken
piccata to it because I was laughing
from it because she was sitting the
[ __ ] back like feminine I might do
something run you know I just couldn't
when I see women like that I think of my
daughter and I think that's what I gotta
put in the book first of all you should
have been with this [ __ ] guy this guy
is just a loser
oh yeah but this poor girl I could just
see the fear in her eyes I could see the
fronton confusion I it's funny because I
want to talk about something you and I
last night we're talking matter you know
I always had a real Terry cause of my
being white moment you get these moments
that you want to be white and you forget
and we're talking about when I went to
University of Colorado
that when I walked on that campus and I
got to talk to different people the
field that wanted to get into his
international law so my plan was to go
to law school and sharpen my Spanish and
go over to Spain and become a lawyer
this is when I was 27 guys and between
you and I it's like that mindfuck like I
didn't want to be anything I wasn't
gonna be anything I didn't have any
confidence to be anything I was just
buying time they were gonna give me
money to go to school when you give me
money I don't give a [ __ ] I'll do
whatever you want me to do as long as
you give me a nice check you know and
it's real how I was 27 28 and I still
didn't [ __ ] know what I wanted to do
like this was nothing this was years
away comedy Carly was still even not
even conceived I was just going to
school selling cars I'm gonna wear a
suit and I would go to these seminars
after like I was telling you like after
class in the Student Center they have
like these companies come in and talk to
you about this and overseas
opportunities and [ __ ] and I would go of
my little pad and sit there may believe
I was taking notes in the back of my
mind that was scared [ __ ] bad I was just
buying [ __ ] time I'm like why am I
doing this this is never gonna happen
you know I kept talking myself out of it
okay
and here I was sitting in a room with
all these people that had like major
different [ __ ] you know degrees and
they as colleges I got a BA from Yale
and you know BS from the University of
Spain and Here I am a [ __ ] I wasn't a
felon yet if I gotten arrested but I
wasn't a felon yeah I was convicted I
was I was charged but never convicted
you know at that time I was a man of
many convictions so uh but it was so
weird how I get emails from people and I
go to shows and I talk to different
people and yeah we got high oh-hoh and
but after a while people come up and
they go Ben thank you you know this
helped me I was stuck in this place and
it's so weird how we're all [ __ ]
stalked man boom [ __ ] stopped the 20s
has to be a horrible time for [ __ ]
anybody you know teenage years and then
20 that's not fair to people yeah that's
really not [ __ ] fair like being a
teenager for 59
a teenager trying to get [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and trying to make him a man in a man's
world and then being 20 and being a
[ __ ] confused on what the [ __ ] you
gonna do and going to bed and having
whole system going Jesus Christ wait I
was thinking about week three three or
four days it's like man I sit there at
night and I think I wanted my let me
don't [ __ ] about guest
well hanging out well having a good time
today today you never know what this
might come into you might get a call
tomorrow floor microphone company and
then likely we love how you talking to
the microphone [ __ ] come be the face
of microphones are us with you with 200
grand E and again you never sit down I'm
taking all calls guys and you're going
Joey I don't even know what the [ __ ] you
how this guy you know how this came to
be you know I hope I mean I hope so and
it's something I've dealt with since
I've been out here I'm I'm always
wanting to do stuff I always want to do
more and I always feel like I'm behind
like I always feel like I'm I'm late but
everyone always tells me like when I
tell one they like hold are you
27:20 and I'm like 2500 you're so young
it never feels like it always feels like
I'm I'm behind people and I'm not doing
what I should be but everyone's like oh
you're so young when I was 25 I had no
idea what I was gonna do you know you
come here twice a week at 6:00 in the
morning
you know what that's like for a 25 year
old kid stuff do you have any idea what
it's like telling a normal 25 year old
they have to have to be somewhere at
6:00 in the morning do you have any
[ __ ] idea when you when people would
tell me how to be somewhere 6 no more I
just look them go write good as long as
you think that that's great when I pull
up here and I see your car here Lee
sometimes I shake my head I'm like when
I find this [ __ ] Savage you don't
know how hard it is to tell a 25 year
old and thank God you don't have a
substance abuse problem or drinking
problem or you even like to go out and
have cocktails do you don't like to go
on tonight not really so yeah I might
hooked up with actually how was that and
her brother where'd you guys go to me we
went to a bar and on Ventura Boulevard
was she looking fine so he [ __ ] a
black dude when she went to Boston now
yes she did
I don't know she really likes the guy
she's with but she didn't [ __ ] he didn't
[ __ ] her right and he got he [ __ ] her
from the bottom I don't know [ __ ] but
anyways great how's the phrase look good
she's just started a new job so just a
lot of breath no did she have sperm out
of Breton she had double ammonia smell
of breath like she just sucked 10
helmets where'd she get in the job I
have to get a job at I don't know
writing place in Van Nuys a writing
place
yeah what kind of writing boy like big
like technical writing so something but
uh you said this a while ago like like
it was leave them alone in the light
you'd be like I haven't seen them in
like four months and that great people I
love her and her brother but it's just
it's uh I don't know it's weird when you
realize it's like okay well we're
friendly but it's now we're gonna hang
out every day and it's when you when
you're younger you think all your
friends are gonna be your best friends
and she still loaded Northridge yeah
they're thinking about moving but to
where here but who knows
you know you look at your friends in a
weird way I have a problem lately I've
been dealing with something lately about
that you know I grew up with a lot of
friends but there was a core there was
three guys that I ran with for 18 22
years I ran with him for a long time
growing up but for two years we became
each other's each other is myself this
guy ferny buster sudo this kid Glen
Conte and this guy Roger Holloway I mean
we were [ __ ] tight tight and tight
you know it started junior year and it
went to 85 if you know our friendship
and our love one another and then left
man my friend ferny disappeared in 81
when 83 when he lost you know $60,000
bookmaking and you know he always felt
because he owed sixty ended up oh and
hate and me I told the guy to go [ __ ]
himself I got in a plane
Colorado so he always felt that I should
have stuck it out here with him while he
was 260-thousand I was gambling for
money for Colorado whether if I warned
it was great if I lost I didn't really
care because I was Nutella gotta shut up
his [ __ ] ass anyway you know I was 21
I didn't know about life I didn't know
that I didn't really know about karma I
thought you just told people to [ __ ] off
and at that time the world had told me
to [ __ ] off so I was telling the world
of [ __ ] off yeah so he when when I got
back in Colorado or from Florida
wherever the [ __ ] I went we were still
friends but it was the same and one day
he told me cuz I always felt that you
know you should have paid him the eight
thousand dollars I pay him 260 I'm like
Dawg I wasn't paying him I explained my
situation and he understood we each
other much and then in 93 I bumped into
him on Kennedy Boulevard and he was with
a girl and he shook my hand and then the
girl says his this is him and then I
bumped into another dear friend of mine
that I spoke to every week now and he
told me that he bumped into him about
ten years ago and how the blue my friend
told my friend it's your fault I'm
[ __ ] up because when we were kids you
had parties at yes so my friends like
are you [ __ ] serious you're doing
heroin we used to drink beers and smoke
pot behind the factory yeah and you're
doing heroin and you're blaming that on
me so his brothers on Facebook and I
haven't asked his brother how the
brothers doing but he never recovered
from that he never really recovered from
the gambling drugs and and then my
friend Glenn who was a big shot at ups I
mean I loved him with all my heart if I
ever had a brother he was with my
brother you know he you know he's into
Joel Osteen and he doesn't drink anymore
he's uh he has two kids with a black
chicken he doesn't he's not with her
okay even with her he just lives by
himself and I hear on the weekends he
goes on and stays on because he's scared
of life you know he's got like three or
four duis ten years ago and stuff so
he's very scary life and then Roger ROG
is my Goomba to the end you know and I
talked to Roger and his brother Timmy
they drove me to Opie and Anthony send
me a claw okay
he was the drive room we Rob Michaels
Julie so in West New York
he was the getaway driver and it's funny
that I talked to him once a week you
know he's a driver in New York and we
communicate once a week you listen to
all the podcasts he listens to you know
and then I love him dearly but his
brother and me with tight I was tight
with all I was tight with the whole
family and when I went to do the stress
factory in Jersey some lady came with me
she's like hey I'm Janet's a hairdresser
and she said to say hello how was that
tight with the Holloway's but Roger
ferny whom Glan I wish I didn't more
with them I wish I get together with
them for a tea you know I don't give a
[ __ ] of coffee but it's never gonna
happen and it's very sad it's saddens me
because I always thought they were there
and trust me I have other friends have
venerian a Scalise and James and George
that I still talk to you know Rafi Mac
told you last night Ralph and recalled
you were there yeah there were a chance
dragon [ __ ] in in rich real
parking in Georgia he says the ribs were
[ __ ] sensational so it really covers
the spread but it's sad because in my
world I still wanted them to be around
and if it was up to me they'd still be
around in the communication bases I
[ __ ] the Glen's brother it's funny I
talked to Glen's brother
Rogers brother and and ferny's brother
but I don't talk to each of them so
that's how tight I was with them and
their families man I mean I was
everything they were my everything so if
it was up to me I wish I could share
what's going on I'm on the podcast talk
about stories they it's it's impossible
and it breaks my heart but it doesn't in
a way I'm happy that they're happy you
know I still talk to Raj is the best one
I still talk when I call Raj he still
calls me Coco Loco and what are you
doing well it's actually kind of crazy
it's uh that's friendship but I had a
dream last night I don't remember
exactly what it was about but it was
about somebody who had been married who
broke up after like a long time and it's
just like you grew up thinking you're
supposed to get married but people
change it's just like like since it's
coming up closer mine's more
my life right now I've been thinking
about it look it's kind of a crazy thing
to do like it's just like Maddie yeah I
mean people change so much and it hurts
so much to break up like why wouldn't
you just stay like what do you do you
live like we're an awesome
no I'm living to one bedroom and wait
for the world and then and then you know
I love Tom like us I look Tom like this
I've been on Tom Leykis I listen to his
show but he's got this world turning
against women turning against women cuz
you had one bad experience mmm listen
man there's a lot of bad people out
there there's a lot of bad women but
there's a lot of good women and women
are gonna cheat on you what am I gonna
steal from me a woman gonna do crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know but there's some
women in a solid women that all they
want to find is love too
oh and all they want is a companion so
you have to live this [ __ ] life man
you have to live this [ __ ] life
oh yeah but let's say even if you get a
good one like not that they cheat on you
but what let's say in ten years you
don't like that music anymore you don't
like volve
Lee exactly why don't I do Joey karate
videos why don't I put a gear on every
[ __ ] week and wrap it around my thing
and have some fat guy with white hair
throw kicks and keep giving you loser
[ __ ] picks in this ten percent of
people your karate is etheric or
whatever because we [ __ ] evolved
exactly you know we evolve as human
beings so but you gotta take that chance
what about the people that have been
married for 50 [ __ ] years they don't
get sick of each other yes for the best
[ __ ]
and not the feeling that is to have a
[ __ ] best friend you know what that
is that you don't have to work forget
the the net for life forget the net for
life there's a net that we have to
remove from life to be anything you want
to be a [ __ ] Melinda you gotta take
that [ __ ] net away mm-hmm well if you
want to be a good friend you gotta take
that net away if you want people gonna
be a friend to you you gotta take that
net away the big problem I have is when
I become your friend I go back to 1970
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we're gonna get in a fight with people
and we're gonna [ __ ] we have each
other's back till the end we get stabbed
we break each other's head whatever the
[ __ ] we'll take each other to the
hospital but we're here to the end of
this [ __ ] my 35 cents how much you got
in your pocket 38 cents we got [ __ ]
72 cents between the both of us we could
take over the [ __ ] world that doesn't
evolve anymore that doesn't happen
anymore
no as people get older they have other
priorities but you know what man I want
my friends to be there forever I want
Timmy out all the way to be there and I
want to talk to a Scalise and I want to
talk to James you know I want to talk to
people that are there for me you know
these are my [ __ ] friends this little
illicit and we have a what's called
acquaintances in life oh my god if you
have a birthday party I'll definitely be
there they show up and they bring you a
bottle of wine and they take pictures
and they hug you those are those people
they're really good in front of the
camera oh my god I love this guy you
know and then you call him at 4:00 in
the morning when you're stuck man I'm
never gonna work in two hours I thought
you loved this guy well let me tell her
[ __ ] love what I'm for the love that
was all for pictures don't you're gonna
have those people yeah then you got them
all the [ __ ] that look you in the eye
and go doggerel 8,000 a bank you want me
to go get it and they got two kids they
got two kids and they're like dogs I got
8800 in the back it's yours for an
attorney and you look at them as a man
you gonna know I'm save it for your kids
as a man because you know you need that
money
but you rather go out and rob for it
before you take your friends [ __ ]
kids money you understand me there's
different things you do as a man I
learned to be a man kid I learned that
both yours and mine were gone for it and
if somebody [ __ ] at you they're [ __ ]
with me and somebody [ __ ] with me
they're [ __ ] with you but that's not
the case bro especially this [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] city that we live in
these people turn their [ __ ] back on
you for no reason
don't those you know people in jobs will
write you off for what a dollar extra an
hour
mm-hmm you're gonna rat somebody out he
he came he takes 55 minute lunches you
should go take a 55 minute lunch you
[ __ ] [ __ ] he parks is calling the
wrong flag he smile gives a [ __ ] maybe
you should grab your [ __ ] balls too
and [ __ ] figure out but no dog and
the same thing happens in this town in
this town people stop talking to you
because you
or something or you did something
positive mm-hmm will you not helping me
what [ __ ] helping you're talking
about what help do you want you gotta
get up in the morning you gotta tweet
you got to do push-ups you got to whack
you off you got to take a shower and you
got to write jokes and you got to go
meet people and you gotta get on [ __ ]
stage that's the formula you know it's
so weird that when I was doing Lisa when
I was in college and I was doing them
there's somebody on Big Joe oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] my man Joe from world of rock
[ __ ] records to leave it and
vinyl what's up my brother
we're boarding you freak how you doing
you know us well over here we're talking
about a weird [ __ ] and how you know man
when I was 27 I had I conned myself into
the University of Colorado Joe and it
was really funny I was going to all
these meetings dressed up in the suit
thinking I was Joe [ __ ] Gentile you
know like I was going to do something
with my life
deep down inside I was a miserable
[ __ ] criminal and I had no future in
the back of my head but there was one
thing I didn't have at that time that I
have now it's the difference and yet
people do change and you want me to tell
what it was I didn't want to work I
didn't want to work I didn't want the
concept of work I didn't like that
concept of work like I wanted to walk
into your job and be the top editor like
I'm not going in there to be the weather
his assistant like there was no work
ethic in my life I didn't even plan on
it like what I got a start as a stock
boy no no no no no I'm going and there's
a manager and I got [ __ ] Saturdays
and Sundays off why do it and that's a
cold reality of life that I had as a
young man but sorry about that joke
hanging tell me something good my
brother cuz you've been a young man you
know we act that's not a typical warning
here it's freezing it's a windy as [ __ ]
I'm in Linden New Jersey I'm getting
ready for the day I got my coffee
I got everything I'm doing I'm doing
everything the way you guys are doing it
let me actually I'm on the other side of
the program no let me
how long have you had world around whoa
it's well the rock is two things it's a
record label okay and it's a music
school okay it's based out of Summit New
Jersey the music schools been there
since summer 2012 and the label started
about I about a year later
so labels going on maybe nine months
eight nine months now and do you guys do
DVDs CDs or just plain a vinyl I mean
you know it it kind of it started sort
of spontaneously it was done mainly to
keep me busy and to just kind of do
music and an art that resonates with me
justice you know what I mean I it
originated it as an outlet to get local
bands heard be that C's vinyl now that
that's you know again anything that was
there was were there really no rules and
it just sort of turned into so far it's
just been all vinyl that we put out I
mean we could really do anything but it
seems like I got want vinyl now more
than anything it's uh my model
collections been growing for the last
couple years you know we've been talking
for the last six months you and I and
I've been watching I'm watching your
tweets I was what you'd do and it's so
weird that you're involved in so many
different things one of the questions
you know I wanted to hook up with you in
New Jersey but it was two things I had
my family lurking and you saw what it
was like Thursday night there was 300
[ __ ] people on my shoulder oh yeah
yeah I know your trip was gonna be
packed for the minute you got here and I
know that I love people who take chances
and you gotta look
in a world of digital downloads this
[ __ ] guy in Jersey wants to open up a
vinyl company and it just I'm not
criticizing you I'm loving your balls
that's why I've been commiserate enough
what are you because I'm like in this
land of downloads where they're closing
all these [ __ ] stores they're closing
everything books borders everything's
getting [ __ ] in the ass even Red
Lobster and I got a close red [ __ ]
Lobster
that's like John Wayne you know here you
are doing finals and you're pushing 12
inches and there's a lot of young people
who don't understand what final is they
don't understand they don't want to
understand and I wish they did you know
it's like people like right now I'm
smoking a vapor patent I have a
dependency and it's great it kills what
I'm trying to get rid of I'm trying to
get work on my lungs I love getting high
but there is nothing listen [ __ ] Medical
Marijuana there is nothing like going
into a black neighborhood and getting a
ten dollar bag of weed and throwing on
these silver and stopping at a fucked-up
store and getting a rolling papers and
driving home with the weed in your car
going upstairs and taking the weed out
and breaking it with your fingers and
cutting it and then cutting the rolling
paper and rolling up a [ __ ] joint
that is what it was a tenderfoot you
know when you listen to music when I
grew up on music you knew what album you
wanted you walk through the store you
bought the album again you got your
goombazz to come over six or seven years
you had two joints you open the album
you rolled it on the album you took it
out of the cover you put the outline you
roll you smoke the reefer while the
album was playing and you read the liner
notes you read the album where was it
[ __ ] recorded who was on it we'd like
to thank the Sheraton centers that was a
karma thing it was the process of the
music that was what it was all about
when I licked a rolling paper and I rip
it and I roll it looks tedious but
that's the process of love I'm taking
that from but all right that's the whole
thing when you buy a CD now you open up
the CD
a picture with a sleeve yeah and there's
no info I don't know anything about them
I don't you know there's nothing in
there you have five square inches to put
all your liner notes all your artwork
all your [ __ ] and then the thing
[ __ ] breaks when you drop it three
feet from the [ __ ] ground
that's a CD you know no I'm with you so
what do you say like how do you even a
Salesman how do you sell records to
people who you can either illegally
download it or download online keep it
on your phone it's with you in the car
wherever you are like tab for vinyl you
have to be like be at home like how
would you sell it to like this
generation well normally I mean now that
now the final the big it's a big
resurgence final that's being sold now
is typically packaged with the download
that comes with it so you get the best
of both worlds you get the digital that
comes with the vinyl but usually and
like at the form of a card you enter the
code in the computer you get it for free
you know I mean it's inside the vinyl
itself then you have the final for the
home you know you sit down you listen to
it as it's meant to be heard as it as a
piece of in Jerry's case a piece of
comedy or you know it's wherever it is
it's art you know it's meant to be paid
attention to and focused on instead of
something disposable to listen to in the
background when you're driving or
something I mean that's fun too that's
what visuals for but the vinyl is for
when you are ready to cue actually
experience the album the way it's meant
to be heard like you know it's a it
takes a certain music person it's a you
know you go to somebody's house and have
a library of books they want you to see
that [ __ ] library they're trying to
show you something nobody puts their
library in the [ __ ]
yeah okay nobody desert no but everyone
wants to show you what books they've
read oh my god did you read all those
books yes I did in time you know
whatever gives a [ __ ]
same thing with music people you know
when I was growing up hey this is my
friendly say hello Haley yeah sit down
guys have a soda have a beer when that
[ __ ] one in the kitchen I get
your beer the first thing you want you
look through his record collection that
[ __ ] had more than two bad
albums yeah they're like a bad call
I see cheap trick live at Budokan and
something Mouse [ __ ] this [ __ ]
it was out there you saw where his head
was at
if he didn't have suppling too if you
even have paranoid if he didn't have
there was certain islands you've got to
have if you didn't have those this
[ __ ] ain't right he's a cop he's
something he's an undercover [ __ ]
witness he's a mambo dancer for the FBI
he ain't right because he ain't got the
right [ __ ] music people like that
people like for you to go in their house
and see what they listen to you know
they want you you know it's making a
resurgence it definitely is I miss it
you know I tell people all the time if
you buy the last well the last Led
Zeppelin arm is Kota I'm talking about
the one before that in through the out
door if you find very store today if
you're not doing anything you drive your
wife to a [ __ ] stupid hair salon we
got a pair of pants as an album store
going then look for the last legs up
around the lack though the one to last
in through the out door pull this lever
you pull the sleeve out if they stook
care of it the sleeve is is a picture of
an ashtray with cigarettes in it a few
loose joints some booze and some pills
and coke you take a sponge and you wet
the sponge and you dry it and you would
wipe that thing and all the colors would
come to life if you understand people
played with that if you look at some
girls you know them by the stones look
at it pull it out it lets you match up
the wigs with the faces of the stones
you know if you look at Led Zeppelin 3
the immigrant song and all that it has a
thing that spins so why you were smoking
dope you could spend this [ __ ] thing
you know the old couch and charm how
them had a rolling paper in it
really [ __ ] rolling paper in it this
is a piece of you hell you're giving to
me I just didn't give you 1699 for a
[ __ ] disc and a piece I'm giving you
you give me a piece of me so yeah I
loved inside covers if you listen if you
get Pink Floyd animals you pulled out
the thing the lyrics were in there
you know though all the [ __ ] songs
there was some neat show Van Halen - had
a poster at David Lee Roth
hanging it with chains and two darts of
that supposed I hate that [ __ ] poser
my point being there was just so much
more life to an album and don't get me
wrong I love cassettes
I love DVDs I love going on that the
iTunes I'm pressing the thing and next
thing you know you listen the [ __ ]
music that's all great and dandy but the
album is for that guy that goes home
he's a STONER he wants to live the
[ __ ] thing he's got the chair you got
leave me and put your feet up and you
just listen to Dark Side of the Moon you
know how many bands how many bands have
put out albums through you guys how many
bands have put out albums for you guys
well you're gonna be the third the third
album we do or the third release our
first one is a seminal single by
actually a very popular rock band that's
been around not around anymore
unfortunately but they do around for
quite some time CKY their lead singer
and the drummer had side project need
foreign objects so we're doing a box set
of those we're doing each single from
one of my favorite albums I couldn't say
no to it we're doing a box set of each
song with a whole lot of b-sides and
there's a pop band from from Australia
called the triangle let's do that a song
and an LG commercial recently that's how
I found out about it and I fell in love
with the song and I found out that it
wasn't pressed on vinyl I said you know
what I guess I got a [ __ ] job to do
so I got in touch with them and they
said hey yeah we could let's do
something let's press in vinyl you know
7-inch single so we're doing that now
three
orders are up and we're gonna do yours
that's what we got going on right now
and we're doing a free compilation we'll
putting together with a whole lot of
local fans but that's not all the works
now you musician also yeah I've been
making music since 2006 I was um had a
band called room machines we're not
we're not really doing anything anymore
but a whole lot of stuff out over the
past seven eight years or so but I
haven't really written anything recently
I've just been kind of in a transitional
phase I just moved back here for PA so
I'm just trying to take a day-by-day
figure out what the whole plan is then
well the rock is really the only thing
keeping me sane that's my beacon of
sanity through the whole thing so I hope
it shows you love what you do Joe I love
it I love it now do a lot of people that
send shows I'm sorry I said I hope that
that show at all I know that that shows
no sure I thought it's a 24/7 thing for
me it's all of it well the rock is a
one-person thing I mean I'm the one that
runs all that I do all the graphics I do
all that everything start to finish so
it's a hell of a job I love
responsibility but it's an interesting
time so I can't say no to it now do you
go out a lot
in Jersey during the week do you go to
different bars and see different bands
or not as much as I should you know as a
record label representative I guess on a
personal level no I mean I don't really
go how much at all I kind of spend all
my time working on something creative
I'm write a lot but I don't I haven't
put anything out a while mostly music
but like I said I'm just trying to
gather what you know I'm just trying to
gather it all together and figure out
what the next step is you know it's
funny because if you're in the music
business you know 15 years ago was like
the comedy business you had to be out
six nights a week yeah you all had a see
the next you know
doesn't want to see the next big the
whole war but at the same time the
internet [ __ ] that up a little bit
because now if I say to you dog check
out you know Jewish lightning you go
home knowing Jewish lightning and there
they are on YouTube or whatever me
before I sign somebody I'm gonna go see
him live I'm gonna go see what they're
putting out I'm gonna go see how they
are with the people afterward how they
are before are they [ __ ] bumbling
buffoons you know but you could just get
it out of way now by turning on YouTube
which works for an artist and doesn't
work for an artist you know I'm
disgusting but if you sit through the
show and calm and watch you know I turn
disgusting into a little nicer than what
it is on stage and make it seem a little
cleaner and then I talked to the people
afterward them and you could sell my
heart and my love is there you'll sign
me if I just send you a YouTube thing
you'll never sign me even from the
beginning when I got here people say
send me a reel and I refuse to send them
because what's the use you're not gonna
do nothing from a couple jokes I want
you to come check me out you know oh
what's what's still open in Jersey to
check I mean when I was growing up his
30 years ago was a hole in the wall you
know the soap factory I mean those are
the big venues I saw Aerosmith there I
still Twisted Sister there you know I
used to you know not not that much I
mean the spelling ponies here the
Starland Ballroom is here right my
friend huh we write Queen Queens right
Rudy Sarzo
was at the spa Starland Ballroom last
week e twitted me the one night where
his Starland Ballroom save us okay
[ __ ] okay and that was Bon Jovi's all
stomping grounds yeah okay yeah he
bailed they were around Woodbridge and
perth amboy which that's 15 minutes for
me I'm in Linden so I'm like I'm right
over one from them Wow
that's [ __ ] amazing yeah I'm like 20
minutes from North Bergen right up 109
Wow Yeah right there 109 is Tunnel yeah
they [ __ ] that's it
we'll [ __ ] Road man yeah you kidding
did you see the vid the trailer that we
put together that I put together for you
for the vinyl I saw the one I want to be
around but I haven't seen the other one
that's it that's the one that was filmed
on route 1 and 9 oh god [ __ ] that I took
my phone out I drove all the way up
towards North Bergen filmed all that
like the skylines and stuff rocket went
came all the way back put it together
put the music to it threw it up there
that was all done in one day
now it's amazing that uh I mean I always
check this out because I I'm thinking of
getting one once I settle I mean be a
waste people keep telling me that if you
go on eBay there's a lot of Turning
Tables on there is that true
like this really sure yeah everything
like anything old no [ __ ] yeah I have no
idea how to use a record player like how
easy they pick up it's not like I do
believe this yeah if I had one I would
have no idea where to put the needle I
have no idea how did you put the noodle
on the record put the needle on the
record
[ __ ] yeah you go on the record putting
the needle on the record is like
lighting a cigarette everybody does it
slightly different
okay okay
my mother [ __ ] as you walked in the
house and I haven't even put sneakers on
don't shake the noodle is very sensitive
there's mother [ __ ] it took that [ __ ]
seriously bro like don't [ __ ] move in
my room cuz the [ __ ] shakes yeah I think
you got somebody told me at a record
store in San Francisco you get a
turntable on eBay now for 100 [ __ ]
bucks sure yeah I mean there there are
people that really strive for the best
possible sound that they can get out of
a out of a record so though they'll
spend a lot of money on a turntable and
you know all the components you know but
they also sell like those novelty old
ones like a target for a hundred bucks
but I would stay away from those if
you're looking for something of peaceful
quality because those are more of a
novelty than anything they look cool but
they tend to disintegrate after right
after a while they're 30 [ __ ] years
old you know they still have that wire
from the [ __ ] needle to the thing
that carries the sound you know I mean
so people are making them brand new is
what you're telling me oh yeah I mean
ever since Michael Caine started coming
back so two turntables yeah it's really
weak because I remember vinyl being huge
and you know you had your cassettes were
coming into the mold and eight tracks
were going and then the big thing was
you had to have reel-to-reel oh my god
that's the only way to listen you could
actually hear him pulling away from the
microphone you know all that dumb
[ __ ] Gentile [ __ ] so that was
everybody went for the reel-to-reel and
I had a buddy who had reel-to-reel and I
got to tell you somebody put Judas
Priest live on there the unleased in
East and they put stained glass on there
and it was the sound was
un-fuckin'-believable so then people
kept saying well the sound is better on
DVD so they went all the way the DVDs
and then all some people said saying not
the sound is better on [ __ ] vinyl and
then when Keith Richards put his book
out
he put a couple chapters out dedicated
to recording of music now how they
[ __ ] it all up they [ __ ] it all up
they can't even do live albums anymore
they forgot how to wire rooms they
forgot how to wire drunk
he does like a whole chapter of this did
you read it at all Joe no I haven't I
was never really big into the stones for
some reason I like the stones and this
is gonna sound terrible but I I dig the
stones more than the Beatles only
because I like having to like their
sound more than than the Beatles I
understand the respect and no no no you
preaching to the choir listen the
Beatles were the Beatles and the stones
are the stones just a [ __ ] dirty the
stones are carried right this is three
other stones at deaf
can dirty and you could feeling the
music and it feels great sticky fingers
is dirty it's only rock and roll's dirty
you know there's a couple hours that
they had during the 70's that are just
so brilliant but that's the brilliance
that they sound dirty
well it is autumn on about them that
documentary is at them yes
oh [ __ ] when they're up in the hot the -
oh I got stabbed yeah and you'll stab
somebody and bla bla bla bla bla bla
yeah the stones were dirty if you look
at the sky yeah look at Keith Richards
and all that Ron Wood came a belong in
73 or 74 they're dirty man not that they
don't take showers
they just their sound is very their
sound
we at the studio we have we have like a
big TV with a DVD set up and we have a
rotating selection of dvds it's the
stones lies again I guess it's a news
live DVD I don't know if there's more
than one it's that Foo Fighters we got
Elvis and I think another one and
they're just constantly on loop just
going every day so it's I mean it's
playing all the time I hear all the time
that's amazing honestly I'm Luke Elvis
was dirty do some of this [ __ ] was dirty
man is dirty that's one thing I never
got into me and I never regret but I
know I don't know the names of all of
like the guitar player for this or the
music was just never was never like it
never did that for my song listening to
guys like talk about all the stones are
dirty but then the Beatles look like
it's a whole new world that's just
exciting to like to get into the Beatles
have how many albums Joe yesterday they
had a lot and put out put out a lot of
albums if it out what to three albums a
year back then cuz albums were the whole
process was a lot simpler and quicker
backbone it what maybe
[ __ ] that couldn't you tell you the
stones put out I gotta say 20 albums
that's conservative you know I don't
think the Beatles got
people are that high of Exile on Main
Street all those uh you know there's
just too many according to wikipedia
says they put out 13 who's that the
stones yeah all right the beatles that's
not right that's all right
I don't think so may could be it could
be it could be what about the stones
let's see you know I was always more of
a Pink Floyd Queen channel is a man
[ __ ] not one of my favorite songs of
all time is definitely two legs I love
that oh my god oh my god oh let me talk
to you about lay at the Opera [ __ ] it
when I to the Opera that's that's a
masterpiece of a noun
I just everytime I blew on will way that
it right now every time I put a song
from that I'm on Twitter people have no
idea what I'm talking about and I don't
tell no idea what went into making no no
what was the one seaside rendezvous oh
my god thinking [ __ ] I forgot all about
that [ __ ]
Oh God before the stones have twenty
four thousand hours 24 hours that's why
they're [ __ ] gazillion is 24 [ __ ]
Elms and the meat of the stones is in
the middle that goat's head soup exile
sticky fingers it's only rock and roll
some girls
that's the [ __ ] heart of the stones
in there that one the one to a Jimmy
Page is on it oh my god they have a lot
of [ __ ] wild music the stones but
that that's 24 [ __ ] hounds last one
was a low five oh yeah they put
something out every couple [ __ ] yeah
and the safety goes I put two out they
put like three or four hundred and
sixty-five and every year sixty sixty
yeah up until yeah you're right Joe I'm
putting in a more at least one here
what's let me ask you this go ahead let
me ask you this are you a bigger fan of
Gilmore's Floyd or waters Floyd I'm a
Gilmore guy all the way to the end yeah
I have no use
I can people gonna be pissed at me I
have no use for he goes and it doesn't
show me a lot to see an ego I just need
to see them walk a manageable ego is
bono and I'll tell you why because
they're still together Roger Waters ego
to get the singer from the police's ego
those were [ __ ] he goes that it's
just too much to feed and that [ __ ]
drives me [ __ ] crazy one of the ego
breaks up a band I eat the police ie you
know whatever the [ __ ] else we were
talking about yeah so Roger Waters I
love again the dirty sound of Gilmour I
love that dirty dogs
you know sheep all that gilmore [ __ ] to
me he's one of the best guitar players
of our time but that's to me we all have
different people I put them up there
with page and the Hendrix's and the
Shankman is and you know her we all have
like different you know people him and
Ryan made of queen or amazing learn how
to do Brian Mays are savage I'm at a
loss as a savage that you never want to
admit it but if you listen to if you
listen to [ __ ] Keith Richards is a
[ __ ] savage an untamed Savage Keith
Richards and if you don't [ __ ]
believe me put on [ __ ] put on sticky
fingers and just focus on his guitar
playing can't you hear me knocking all
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] heroin friend your
fingers that's if he touches you you're
high for two [ __ ] days and that's
what happens that's what happens to you
when you listen to that [ __ ] you know I
love everything listen man I love
everything I can't argue mature people
and the biggest arguments out get him
the angrier I get is about music because
it's plain and simple I was taught some
of the other day if there was it let it
skin it would have lived do you know how
different society would have been
tonight because the cars wouldn't have
been popular a lot of that music will
never came out if Leonard's been able to
live they would arise up they would
arised up out
laws would arised up all those southern
based type bands would have [ __ ] jump
right up that would have made room for
nobody they were eating people alive
I've said this for years look at [ __ ]
who read all read up on when they opened
up for the stones in that worth it was
two different [ __ ] worlds even the
stones couldn't believe how good leather
skin it was they couldn't believe it
that these guys were [ __ ] crazy
somebody wrote me a thing yesterday when
are you coming to Jacksonville
[ __ ] that boredom [ __ ] town but you
know that's [ __ ] boredom town
produced some of the best [ __ ] guitar
players in the history of American music
the guitar player from the Eagles the
guy they threw out and [ __ ] found
patty as a matter of fact [ __ ] he was
Tom Petty's guitar player in high school
did you [ __ ] know that Doug whoa did
you know that the guitar player from the
Eagles taught Tom pay the guitar in high
school tell me what Tom Petty's another
savage saying you gotta get into him
there's a couple hours that he's [ __ ]
heavy-duty when they [ __ ] kidnap the
chicken sounds of lambs they played Tom
Petty Tom Petty's a [ __ ] savage dog
world the rock what do you where do you
want to take this label to I mean you're
doing Connor I'm doing my next down with
you guys with this album you can't eat
[ __ ] with a I'm gonna put out on vinyl
for the connoisseurs of vinyl you know
because when I listen to [ __ ] comedy
I learned to listen to comedy on pink on
out you know whatever his name was prior
prior on vinyl you know I had Collin on
vinyl and if you left the vinyl or the
window the Sun would melt the vile a
little bit yeah it would have a little
bump into it so all the music and like a
little bump into so you got to put it
back by the window and adjust it when
they got warm again [ __ ] tremendous
huh
yeah be very careful me yeah oh yeah you
always got to be careful so he's good to
stack them vertically too because if you
stack them horizontal that if there's a
piece of dust or a speck of something in
there it can scratch the groove so
everyone staggered vertical
and scratch it you wanted to [ __ ]
stab him 50 times like dog when I gave
you this album there was a scratch yes
it was it bumped at that party listen
man I'm I'm happy to the time to call in
today Joe I love you to all my heart I
think you're a good little [ __ ] guy
doing a good thing and you're doing it
for the for the right cause you know
it's really cool to hear all the morning
yeah you're doing it for the right boy
and listen bro I can tell when
somebody's faking the funk and I could
tell when somebody's putting everything
they got into this and I want to do you
know you can't eat [ __ ] with asthma
we're gonna [ __ ] them print up I gotta
get you some pictures together an alpha
wanna do my oh yeah and I want to do
like a Pink Floyd thing put all three of
them together on violin like a big cover
I have a couple there are a couple
surprises for the final two one in which
will make each single copy different
from all the rest one of them involves
my good friend water boxer and the other
two gentlemen that I was with when I saw
you in Jersey are going to be helping
with the the final step of the final
part or the vinyl pressing process like
I tell you what it is yet you'll find
out that's why I love you brother
how cool is [ __ ] water boxes I was
one a lot of bad [ __ ] everybody
on there Lucas early on don't fake the
funk they had me on I was actually I
called them to leave he was episode six
like it was six or seven did you call in
Italian thank you thank you for
supporting the flying Jew radio you're a
good man so I'll give you a call from
Florida and we'll put this together
brother I love you and I've been
watching in I don't want you to think I
create to the wolves sometimes you know
there's no no water or prompts went on
and people call them in a bad position I
got the baby on one on
yelling into the phone or something you
know man this is it's a different life
when you you want you to sprinkle the
child in that it adds a different
[ __ ] view this life so that's why but
I love your brother thank you for
calling our world of rock now where's
your webpage at just go to facebook.com
slash the world of rock records if you
want to check out the records we after
sale its world of rock records about Big
Cartel calm we still have to put a
website together I'm getting on that now
and twitter.com slash world of rock Rex
our VCS if you're an artist and you want
to submit your music to a world of rock
my man Joe you know him and send it over
and you never know what he could do for
you I love you Joe thank you for [ __ ]
looking bro this means a lot to me with
the vinyl so I love means a lot to me -
you have no idea
stay black oh I stay warm in Jersey
[ __ ] I'll try I love this [ __ ] I
love Italy I love what we're doing
cartel a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive get up do some jumping jacks and
look at the sky thank whoever Buddha
Jesus Satan for giving you another day
that's what I'm saying beside water box
I want to give some shoutouts to my main
man John Diaz - Joe Ando - Mario Fusco -
Tammy rather I love you my love and wolf
hashtag who's always [ __ ] there for
me well that [ __ ] is awesome
no wolf hashtags a bad [ __ ] dog
you know we were very blessed because I
hate saying that word blessed I sound
like one of those black housewives from
[ __ ] Atlanta cousin bliss get the
[ __ ] out of West your [ __ ] that's
what I thought don't I look you look
that's a black house we're from Atlanta
that's what she always liked but I
switched my nuts
I might scratch my nuts and make you
sniff my fingers [ __ ] what's your
favorite Real Housewives I had no idea
you have to put one night I was and the
[ __ ] I couldn't find the remote I was
watching a black housewives arabes
dressed on white everybody's drinking
martinis
yeah we're gonna [ __ ] do this anyway
how about I want to thank my sponsors my
main [ __ ] on it always there
for me
solid [ __ ] sending out a great
product you know getting you people up
to the next level whatever would maybe
strength and during scardy or whatever
the [ __ ] they got everything for you
ropes kettle bells battle ropes vests
they got digest times they got protein
powder
they got [ __ ] or herb hemp flowers
force candy bars chocolate protein bars
they got think that the bread and butter
is [ __ ] out for brain if you're not
taken out for branding you're walking
around like a [ __ ] it's your [ __ ]
fault alright if you're walking around
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's because
you're not taking alpha brain give it a
[ __ ] shot okay you're breathing heavy
you want more endurance I've been
telling you some [ __ ] mushroom tag
tremendous loot exports you wanna you
immune you're hanging out with a bunch
of people with the his well they got
foot fungus get [ __ ] a shroom tech
immune take care yourself that's all I
ask you you go to something Joey Diaz
dotnet and then that [ __ ] thing on
that page and conglomeration of dates
and t-shirts and gods there's a box it
says on it you put what in the box leave
Church church and you get 10% off let's
say you're stupid let's say that you're
[ __ ] busy with your life you can't put
it together you want alpha brain sent to
your house every [ __ ] month you go to
that box you stay on it program you next
to 20% off and they ship it right to you
on the first of every month like a
welfare check okay that's number one
number two Dollar Shave Club how many
times you got to talk about this [ __ ] if
you're a man and you're not using Dollar
Shave Club you're not getting a break on
this [ __ ] it's because you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] or something's wrong with you I
love you to death this is a dollar six
dollars and nine dollars a month times
12 you can't [ __ ] lose even if you get
the six dollar package where they saying
you for raises a month with the alo
blade in the whole [ __ ] deal six
dollars how much is your time worth you
[ __ ] you want to go down to a store and
stand there and wait online and you
don't have to do you have your PIN
number so we can run it through who
gives a [ __ ] later you just give me my
[ __ ] razors I got [ __ ] to do no you
don't need that no more
go to Joey beers but Annette and
box there's a box of [ __ ] Dollar
Shave Club what are you putting that
church Church CH you are CH you know
what is a Sesame Street
you get [ __ ] it's sent to your house
the first of the month they send you an
email your box is being sent you can
track it not only that you want to wipe
your ass want the snow like that mitt
who doesn't days I'm talking about one
wipe Charlies you want something better
than [ __ ] shave cream they got that
cocoa butter with the low barking it
removes the [ __ ] ingrown hairs you're
a [ __ ] Savage I don't want to go over
this again with you bu people you
[ __ ] aggravate me the same thing with
this other [ __ ] this naturebox the best
I just got another box today those
[ __ ] mustard pretzels makes your box
ain't [ __ ] around dawg and when
you're flying because I mean snacks are
expensive when you fly I just throw in a
bag like a [ __ ] weekend with nature
bots I look like a TOC those Gentiles
yeah I got a plane with a Subway
sandwich yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] either you bring the t-bone
you ain't bringing nut don't show up
there with a [ __ ] McDonald's burger
but naturebox it's a good idea to fly
thank you hotel you'll be a high-rise is
why I love you just why I keep you
around you know I know you wonder about
snacks come to me for know about albums
go to see you thank you for being here
today
nature's box get 50% off your [ __ ]
first door to go to Joey Diaz nothing
that go to nature's box and what do they
got Joey Joey jail where you are I go to
nature box.com little bit snacks they
got you could change em up every month
is it a thousand different orders
definitely get the coke coke cupboard
[ __ ] ovens and for my main
[ __ ]
nailed it life calm look how easy and
nice this is this is a heavy [ __ ] pen
right here I use both of them I use the
[ __ ] this one Eureka but it's very
light this I could use as a weapon this
is not gonna fall twice and [ __ ]
break you drop you fall a you Rica falls
you're done this thing here you got two
compartments you got the bottom piece
right here and you can put your [ __ ]
oil in there baboom
and you put this in or you can under the
top over here like this right and you
can put a ball of [ __ ] wax in here
that'll send you
damn Jupiter I'll show you how we do it
right here you take this boom you rub
this in your [ __ ] fingers like that
it feels like boom like a [ __ ] snot
you bend your finger a little sticky
like a key you put this thing here no
blowtorch no [ __ ] nothing I'm doing
this for you today cuz it's Wednesday I
love you people I know that people you
listen you're going joy but we can't see
I want you to [ __ ] close your eyes
and sniff I'm gonna blow a [ __ ] smoke
hot oil lung going right at you and they
can't see now YouTube isin taking down
that video I put up so it looks like
taking the music out it's gonna work
okay so here you go you hear that cook
I'm percolating you hear that people
that's like the smell of napalm in the
morning
listen again and they really oh yeah so
I'm telling you people never like calm
why are you [ __ ] around with
substitutes go to nail that life.com go
to the page you telling my cents you get
20% so ideas yeah like a [ __ ] doctor
that's how we're doing it on Wednesday
March 26 who's better than you you
understand me
I'm leaving tomorrow morning for the
Fort Lauderdale improv ticket to selling
like hotcakes don't come crying to me
look Joey I can't get tickets [ __ ] you
should've gone on Tuesday I know you
broke put on the credit card who gives a
[ __ ] hang up payment yeah it's really
cool but my dad lives in the area and he
took me up there they have like went to
a sushi bar right in the right next to
the casino go up there for like a whole
night it's really fun and cool I took
casino yeah they have a sushi bar on
they give you like cotton candy at the
end we sat at the sushi bar with like a
really cool old Asian guy so you went to
the Hard Rock come on oh yeah like three
or four years ago you could leave [ __ ]
swing in Dickens I don't mess around I
go and I I scoped out all your all your
tour dates yeah you know about [ __ ] like
that I want you to put
The Rolling Stones hot stuff and this
house this is what this is what the
stones did for dirty like that they're
just dirty and I love them I love all
that chin for you people don't know
43 April 3rd April 5th I'm at the Tempe
improv with my other favorite Jew
[ __ ] Ari Shaffir and I don't
know if you people remember Saturday
night my main man and my brother and my
mentor in a lot of ways that he Bravo
metamoris you could download it because
the tickets are sold out they're 100
dollars a ticket but you can still
download it for 30 bucks or 20 bucks 20
bucks I know Lee will be down at leak
and come over later you gotta help me
download it on my phone you can't down I
mean they're just a nice treatment it's
like a swimming on my iPod yeah yeah
yeah so I go to metamoris calm pay for
it and I could streaming hmm you're a
[ __ ] genius that's why I love you is
that hot stuff oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is
Wednesday get up wash that [ __ ]
[ __ ] goalies what huh there's a
bumper loveliest Wednesday March 26th
you bad [ __ ] what are you gonna
do sit there with a thumb up the ass I
like that we get to get what belongs to
you [ __ ]
your lunch money isn't somebody's pocket
and you're sitting there here he's Joey
the church walk then get some [ __ ]
cash
- Parris right you [ __ ] memoirs I
don't give a [ __ ] stab a [ __ ] you
something fill it do something you only
get one shot this [ __ ] life film say
where's the national animal that's what
the problem is nobody for our members
they're a [ __ ] American no more you
understand me
get up that's it I'm pissed off today
get up get up you're a [ __ ] American
people forget every week well where's
the missing plane who gives a [ __ ]
they're in the Indian Ocean now they
found 150 [ __ ] parts that belong to
it for 10 days nobody found [ __ ]
nothing but now today they found 113
parts they just showed up for a week
they didn't know where it was they
didn't even though the Turkish shot it
down but oh [ __ ] it's your chance to
prove yourself justify your existence
you're a [ __ ] American you didn't
wake up with a [ __ ] towel on your
head getting chased by [ __ ] of
Russians you didn't wake up bringing a
black kid under a [ __ ] tree with no
breakfast and flies on top E you didn't
wake up in some [ __ ] firing country
where they're whipping in you're sucking
some [ __ ] old man's dick but you're
sitting there complaining about
insurance and there's no work and
there's no construction go [ __ ] yourself
get up grab your balls I think God puts
you in this [ __ ] planet for what the
[ __ ] TV put you in the United States
for to be a [ __ ] jerk-off from the
watch Kim Kardashian with [ __ ] Kanye
West on vogue who gives a [ __ ] about
those two [ __ ] then getting
somebody to peel blueberries and freedom
to them you gotta go out there and get
the [ __ ] up and wash your balls and wash
your [ __ ] head and grab your [ __ ]
heart you got to get out there [ __ ] Kim
Kardashian from Good Morning America
truckball this not at all about you
today
you're a [ __ ] American grab your gun
[ __ ] loaded with bullets and get the
[ __ ] out there and take what belongs to
you the same way the [ __ ] pilgrims
did [ __ ] have a great day I
love you stay black and stay [ __ ]
strong you're the church that means
you're a savage [ __ ] I love you
Lee close this [ __ ] up today I'm
[ __ ] fired up well bother Dale here I
come on getting on a plane to mom on it
if you got him smoke them you bad
[ __ ] [ __ ] good morning American
all those [ __ ] [ __ ] trying to sell
you computer parts in the morning
you gotta sell you you mother [ __ ] it's
all about you today now the show's over
don't forget to sign up for Dollar Shave
Club com
I love smoking marijuana who doesn't get
high-quality razors sent to your door
each and every month for a fraction of
what they cost at retail go to DA shave
club calm promo code Joey our church or
go to Joey Diaz dotnet and click on the
- a club banner now the show's over
remember go to naturebox calm and order
great tasting healthy snacks at 50% off
snack smarter in the new year with
healthy and delicious treats like
everything bagel chips and sweet potato
fries support this podcast and get half
off of your first order for
naturebox.com/tyler go Joey that's
naturebox compromise OE and again go to
nailed it life calm for all your oil and
wax smokers out there
I'll get 20% off of the best paper pen
on the market that's right
[Music]